this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsay personality rachel cruz hosting
today live here in nashville tennessee
next to me is dr john deloney so we're
taking your calls it's a free call
anywhere in the country at eight eight
two five
five two two five
and what's fun about this this whole
setup here is that you can travel in
hang out with us we have some great
people here in the lobby today watching
the show
get a cup of coffee
some goodies eat some
eat some cookies drink some coffee and
somebody's got incredible hair out there
and you need to do that rachel oh yeah
she's got like purple hair it's
fantastic rachel's gonna do this i'm on
it i'm on it well done there's stuff you
see and you're like i couldn't just
never pull that off like you see things
i wish i could pull you know what i
can't pull off hats
you can't there's like those wide
brimmed
hats you know you see like hats inside
like i can't i can't do that not a hat
person not a hat person but i know what
i'm getting you for christmas
uh but again it's a free call anywhere
in the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so this article
came through john uh and it was just
fascinating that this couple
bought a shed
and turned it in to their home
and then sold it for a profit they made
money off of it yeah did you get that
did you get that uh
and this is like this is like a
fantasy is the wrong word here but this
is like a thing i dream about like i
want to get some land and then just go
to home depot and buy a shed and make it
incredible and no i'll never do that and
they did it yes they did it and money
off they did they sold it or i guess
they had um
acreage or another farm or a house sold
it for 312 000 april 21 after living in
it slightly longer than a year or is
that the shed
they didn't sell the shed for that much
did they yeah is that what it was have
you been to home depot lately well
that's where they bought it sheds are
300 000 they're not really i'm just
being silly oh my gosh i was like wait
what yeah and i think there was actually
a tick tock video
right that we can play and see but they
okay that's way nicer than what i was
expecting
too it's got like it's got a porch
it's got a porch it's two stories
okay i when i had pictured when i read
the article was something
way different than that right there
that's pretty nice no and then they put
wood floors in it and it's got like uh
you know granite countertops and stuff
it's really nice inside see there you go
and so they just said that people were
burdened by debt and the weight of life
and
they didn't want that to be their story
so they yeah just went to a different
stream which things are so we're hearing
that all over the place that people are
like i'm just gonna sell my house to
move to an rv and or i'm just
i want people to be careful though
because there's a lot of folks that
watch a lot of hgtv and a lot of youtube
clips about living in a in a
shipping container and a van down by the
river right or whatever be careful
because that looks really cool there's
some great shows that you can go look
documentaries on i moved into a tiny
home and then four months later like
here was my actual life terrible it's
not great right so it's just it's just
different and i feel like too a little
bit of the gen z
the the younger level of the millennials
that is that's a thing though to go buy
a school bus or to go by then you know
oh i mean it looks incredible uh but you
but again on instagram you'll see like a
reel and you're like oh my gosh you get
to go there and you're sleeping here
like the whole thing and it looks
glamorous and wonderful
and then yeah you don't see there's a
reality to it that's hard everything
else everything but i do like the idea
of just opting out and i think you and i
talked about this on another show my
wife and i moved into like a residence
hall like a door right with a
two-year-old and we did it for a year
and cleared up our lives changed our
whole so there is a season to do that if
you're gonna get radical uh it's not
always a forever solution for most
that's right all right we're gonna go to
the calls and stephen from lexington is
up hey steven welcome to the show hey
good afternoon how are you doing
absolutely good how are you
i'm doing well good how can we help
so i had a i got a question my soul my
wife hit me up the other day and
informed me she has 30 000 credit card
debt that
i didn't know she had
we've been married for about 20 years
we've got a 20 year old and a 16 year
old
and
so she's done this to me once before she
racked up 25 000 in credit card debt
and i didn't really watch your show then
so i kind of
blew my top and split up our accounts
and took all the credit card debt myself
and got it paid back off
and i really thought if she got him in
the credit card they would you know
she wouldn't get a horrible limit she
wouldn't get a big limit this time
because it wouldn't be bumping both our
names anyway
yeah and uh looks like i was wrong
so now so now she's informed me that she
wants to her zero percent on her credit
cards are expiring
and she wants to take out a home loan
against her house that's paid off
no
no you don't want to take a lean against
your house no no that's that's a that's
a hard no okay so steven where you guys
are at
just in marriage
would you consider yourselves on the
same page with money are you guys still
living pretty separate lives
cash only person i mean i know y'all
don't yeah i don't agree with it but i
still have a credit card but i don't use
it
so uh
my debit card stephen um she's not on
the phone so i'm just gonna address you
is that cool
that's fine um
so
she did something she violated your
trust right the first time around
violated your trust was deceitful we
call that financial infidelity here i
just cheated on you with money she lied
to you
and
another way to look at that is she acted
like a child right she's acting childish
i want it now i'm going to do whatever i
have to do to get it now
and you responded like a child
you threw a temper tantrum
you split everything up you yelled and
you kicked and screamed and you took
your ball and i'm going home and i'll
just do it myself
and now you found yourself right back in
the same spot
and so with this
situation neat this isn't a math problem
i mean it's clear it's a math problem
like rachel said absolutely
don't put your house up on the block to
clear up this mess
right you're gonna have to have some
some directed behavior change inside
your house
but brother it you aren't just not on
the same page when it comes to your
marriage you're not on the same page
with much anything would be my guess
and you've been probably great roommates
and good buddies um
but this is a wake up wake is that fair
pretty much right okay that's pretty
that's right so there's a a place where
she is violating your marriage covenant
she's lying to you
there's also a place where
she can't talk to you
because maybe you blow your top maybe
you get pissed off and run around and
then just solve the problems and so this
can become either the thing that breaks
breaks your marriage up and you say i'm
done with you you don't tell me the
truth i'm out of here or this can be the
moment that you stop the music you throw
all the lights on in the disco and you
look at her in the eye and say we've got
to heal us
and that's going to start with us
getting honest about where we are fixing
our marriage and then getting serious
about money because steven you know when
we hear
these kinds of numbers or situations
for us we're like okay there's a money
problem obviously and there's a tactical
way to go about that the zero percent do
you take it in my house and all that
but really what we're hearing though is
underneath the surface that there are
more marriage issues than even financial
issues and when you guys can get the
marriage issues solved out of that comes
healthier habits with money that you
guys think can work as a team because
right now you're not working as a team
with your money and just like john said
probably a lot of other areas in life so
i would really it's a symptom this
credit card debt is a symptom of things
going on in the marriage so i would
encourage you guys get some help get
therapy get counseling and start working
on your marriage and then your money
becomes more of a team
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
ramsey personality rachel cruz hosting
this hour with dr john delony and david
is up next in richmond
hey david welcome to the show
hey how you doing
we're doing great how can we
so
help
i uh have 19 000 owed on a truck
and i was wondering if i should
sell it i can get between 21 and 28
and buy
another vehicle that i found
another truck for 14 000 cash
okay
um
how much other debt do you have besides
the truck
that's it just the truck oh it's just
the truck how much do you make a year
um
i'm not exactly sure right now i'm
bringing home about 2 000 a week
2 000 a week okay
yeah so
i'm unsure about before taxes
okay
yeah so it'll be a little less than 100
okay
um
do you have four do you have 14 000 in
cash
um i have 34 000 in cash why you just
pay off the truck david yeah
well i i really don't
don't want it anymore
oh
okay you don't care for it it's kind of
like
well it's uh it is a 1500 truck and uh
2500 would really suit my lifestyle
better
[Laughter]
[Music]
fantastic
that's the first time i've ever heard
somebody say it's a 2500 that really
will suit my lifestyle
does that mean you're going up and try i
don't know
so you need a bigger you need a bigger
truck that means he needs to be able to
haul more to haul more oh so you're
actually hauling you're not just like
wanting to show up at the club a little
bit louder a little bit cooler
no no you're not okay
david i think you are yes i'm with you
david john's not but i'm with you no i'm
not i
i don't even know what that means okay
so my thing is so you don't want the
current truck you have
you can sell it for 28 and then you can
turn around and pay cash
for the actual truck that you want is
that what i'm hearing
right yeah do that today
yeah your gas price will double but do
it today why would you not what's what's
what are you what would what would cause
you not do what caused you to even call
and ask
so
um a dave ramsey nut
basically and other than
financing that darn truck
um
i mean i've worked really hard to save
up 34 000 i went today i pulled the 14
out in cash
and i almost had a panic attack just
looking at it is that your emergency
fund dude
oh i guess you could i don't know you
could consider it my six months
well it would definitely last longer
than six months yeah you're you're in a
spot yes i would
sell the truck
make some profit off of it take some of
your savings put it together and go buy
a truck in cash that you can afford and
then you're gonna be even probably past
baby step three at that point with a
fully funded emergency just lock up your
emergency fund and never ever spend it
out of it ever unless it's an actual
emergency this isn't an emergency this
is something that's gonna fit your
lifestyle
that's a different thing right
right and i also have another truck
that's just older a lot more miles
that's what i'm using to work out of
because i do a little bit of landscaping
and tree work on the side yeah so that
that thing is
it's on its last leg but i'd like to get
rid of this newer one get another new
well not new truck at all it's a 2005
but uh another really
nice truck
that can tell a lot more it'll be better
set up for my lifestyle yeah do it do it
do it quit thinking about it
get it done
it done you got it david lock up that
emergency fund put it away and then get
on to with your life yeah and i think
that and i feel
and we could be different on this but
i'm like i kind of feel semi-justified
for him using that savings because
it's he has more in it than what he
needs for his emergency funds right
and
he's going to be in a position where
he's on baby he's getting rid of that
truck
pairing some money together 40 yeah for
what he needs and he has the extra
margin so that's great great call david
thanks for thanks for the question up
next we have andrew in phoenix hey
andrew welcome to the show
hey rachel and john how's it going
great how can we help
hey so my wife and i were 27 years old
we followed the ramsey plan but we have
credit cards for the sole purpose of
buying a house one day
and so i'm willing to get rid of the
credit card but i don't see a clear path
to buying a home using manual repair
writing um can you just walk me through
that process and what it looks like yeah
you're kind of breaking up a little bit
andrew um
so uh yeah so basically what manual
underwriting is is where the where you
don't have a score and it's not a score
of zero it's basically an undetermined
score because you have paid off all of
your debt you have no debt on record for
close to 24 months
credit score so your your credit score
will start to lower as you're paying off
debt
because the way your credit score is
calculated mathematically is all around
debt so it's you know how much you're
paying on your debt how much new debt
you're acquiring your debt history all
this so if you stop going into debt and
you pay it off naturally that score is
going to lower and it's going to take
about 24 months for it to basically get
to undetermined 18 to 24 months
and then from there when you go and get
a mortgage you do the process called
manual underwriting and that's where the
mortgage company actually has to look at
you the person versus just a credit
score
they look at you so you have to have
really on record an employer for two
years to show that you have income a
stable job
and you have to be current on all of
your bills so your cell phone
electricity so you keep track of all
that and to prove
that you have paid on time bills for two
years and usually those things together
maybe some more paperwork it's it
definitely is more of a
confusing
labor-intensive process to do manual
underwriting versus just a credit score
because again when you have a credit
score it's a score and it's just you get
it or you don't i mean it's that simple
where manual underwriting they actually
have to look at you the person so
there's some investigating that they do
but then the mortgage company
will
literally just underwrite you the
mortgage they'll just write it
themselves basically in a sense to
always picture it uh
and you can go through the process so um
and if you've ever in the last few years
now is the time right because mortgage
companies
are not having the years they've had the
last few years yes and so if you sit
down and say i want to do manual
unwriting they'll work with you yes
and having a good down payment to andrew
so when you guys go into
purchasing a home you want to make sure
that you're completely debt free
and you have a fully funded emergency
fund in the bank and then separate from
even that savings that you guys have a
good down payment so if you're
first-time homebuyers you know five
percent is kind of the low end if you
can get up to 20
you can avoid pmi and you save some
money
and that's ideal i know that's not the
case always for people um
but that's that's kind of the formula we
look at and that your mortgage payment
is no more than 25 of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed rate
so if all of that kind of works andrew
um
yeah then that's what you do and again
mortgage companies they they still do
this process some won't like i've talked
to people like why tried with this bank
or this and they they said no so you do
have to shop around churchill mortgage
um is a company nationally that for sure
does that we endorse them because they
are some of the top ones that help
people get homes without a credit score
doing the ramsey way and what we teach
so
it is possible andrew and yeah that's
exciting it's always blows my mind
um how that conversation never happens
like nobody knows that even exists
there's an alternative pathway there's a
way to opt out of the system right and
to still get the home that you want
still do the things that you need to do
in your life um these people just don't
know i don't know yep and andrew too i
would encourage you guys just get rid of
the credit cards like if the sole
purpose
was to have them to build up this credit
score of a credit score that you don't
even really need when you buy a home
then get rid of them just don't even
have the temptation there yeah i
i think back to college i had a credit
card that i just used to pay off
everything
until that one month that
my reimbursement check came in and my
transmission fell out of my little 88
cell hatchback
and i have a check and i have no
transmission
so i took that check and i fixed the
transmission and now i've got a credit
card bill right and i've never had a
bill but i didn't have the money to pick
it up and all of a sudden
oh that's how that happens i was just
playing the game it was always going to
be a dollar for dollars it was never
going to happen to me and then it did
right
and everyone's like well i just have it
just in case there's an emergency you
know we never use it but it's just there
and i'm like okay and then christmas
sneaks up and you're like oh crap we
gotta get here
this one time somebody gets sick and we
gotta buy tickets right now yeah we
gotta get airline tickets just go ahead
and do it you know
life starts happening
and visa i'll get you caught your slack
they had a plan so have a plan america
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so with the rising costs of everything
these days i just feel like people are
worried about their bank account so
they're gonna have enough month to month
because of inflation gas
uh price of groceries everything but the
good news is no matter where you're at
today with your money no matter the
state of the economy you can build a
path towards building wealth and so at
our building wealth live events you'll
learn simple common sense principles to
build real lasting wealth and this tour
for the fall y'all it's been blowing up
earlier this week we announced our
september 13th show in phoenix is
already sold out as well as sacramento
and so the rest of these events you want
to get tickets for because they're yeah
they're continuing to sell outs
but phoenix we actually added a date so
we'll be there september 13th but that
show is sold out but we're going to come
a day early so we'll be there september
12th so that date is added so that is an
opened up night in phoenix
sacramento november 1st sold out
minneapolis november 10th tickets still
available in san antonio november 15th
tickets still still available and passes
start at just 25
and you get a four pack starting at 60
if you go to ramsey solutions.com
slash events to reserve your seats and
those cities
and those are those are fun events they
are fun we we did a few this spring
really was our first time back i feel
like in
since the world shut down two and half
years ago uh and so we were glad just to
be out again we just went we went to
orlando and vegas and did the show and
it was it was so fun so fun to meet all
of you guys so many fans of the show my
favorite part is people don't get to see
us
behind closed doors right and
how we all roll our eyes or be like
that's stupid or we challenge each other
and so we just brought all that on stage
right so we have good information and we
and we also have like oh i think you're
wrong and here's why and i i just love
the yeah love the the people getting to
see this is how these guys really yeah
their friends how they interact it's
john myself uh george campbell ken
coleman and dave ramsey and so part of
the event yeah we're just sitting around
a table discussing current events and we
all have a little bit of different takes
and opinions on certain things but the
overall value and principles of building
wealth you know we definitely all land
in the same way but the way we go about
that some
something different but it's good
sometimes somebody will say like no ah
pretty sure we landed on the moon and
then other people at the table
like rachel will say
never happened
i'm just saying it's during the cold war
the soviet union was sketchy we really
tried to race to the moon so i'm saying
there we go i would just not be sure i'm
not gonna get into it we can have a
conspiracy theory
segment later that would be fun
dave would fire us but it would be
really fun
okay up next is
cindy in anchorage alaska
hey cindy welcome to the show
thank you how are you we are doing well
how can we help
well we had a bit of a situation up here
we are currently in baby step two
plugging along
um but several weeks ago we had a major
house fire oh my gosh
yeah it's okay um we're very blessed
that my husband is is healing quickly
he's he's nearly healed and we all made
it out
and even the dogs and and cats oh cindy
that's so scary very well given the
situation
was it a total loss of your place
um it's in it's not habitable we have
major
rebuild in our future and we can't even
get to the start of the rebuild until
next spring and we'll hopefully be in
our home again by christmas 2023 is the
hope
okay uh i don't even know why you're
calling but before we get going can i
challenge you on one thing
yes sir and then after i challenge you
then you can ask the question unless you
just hang up on me and say this guy's a
[ __ ]
um
one of the great curses of our time
is comparison of grief
okay something happens to us that's
devastating hard scary frustrating
annoying
and we our first thought is
because we have no cultural capacity to
be sad we don't have any space for it
right if if your mother passes away you
get three days off of work and you
better be back here and if it's a
grandparent or a cousin if you have
vacation time you can go right we have
no cultural capacity for just stopping
and saying this is awful
and the way you presented it's fine
everything's good um a husband's healing
and uh we lost everything in a year and
a half we'll have our house
here's the thing your body to quote
vanderkulk is keeping the score
you can pretend and play that it's all
going to be great
i think it's
really important to spend some time
being real real sad
that's interesting because i no one
including myself can figure out why i
haven't cried about this yet i'm not
really sure if i haven't most of the
time when i've worked with people behind
closed doors who say that line
closely behind i don't know why i
haven't cried yet
is
if i started crying i don't think i'd
ever be able to stop
understand and so
key you don't have to quote unquote cry
there's not a right way this is going to
look for everybody some people just
simply don't
but it is important and also it's a gift
to your kids because your kids are still
probably scared they're still mourning
they're still they lost their stuff
unfortunately unfortunately we don't
have children okay okay um
yeah
we have dogs
oh we have a dog mom on the phone all
right but hey um
but here's the thing grief together
okay absolutely i know the temptation
and it feels like it's right to make
everything look great so husband can
feel better man you all lost a lot okay
we we did yeah we definitely did yeah
and you're gonna rebuild out of the ash
together and what comes next is going to
be incredible but it takes a season of
grief all right so that's all that so
how can we help
oh i do well first off i really
appreciate you telling me that because i
was wondering if there's something wrong
with me for not losing my mind yet no
you probably haven't exhaled yet
yeah not not really we're we're very
busy um i have a full-time job i have a
secondary job and we run i help my
husband run his company in the western
world we use uh
busy as xanax
pretty much i'm trying not to i just
can't
work doesn't stop so it's a little
difficult especially in baby step two
yeah if there's immediate concerns do i
pause or keep pushing um
my situation is as follows if i can just
explain it for just a moment yeah is
that do i have a little absolutely yeah
okay
so immediately you know house burns down
um homeless
uh we
a friend brought in a fifth wheel it's
older you know leaks not things aren't
working things like that so we're kind
of sheltering in place in there
um we were on a generator until a couple
weeks ago we finally have temp electric
so we do have like power and stuff now
however and i've got a hot spot so i'm
working but our our options are are as
follows of what we're thinking about
doing and i don't know if i'm thinking
about this just completely
psychologically or what the actual
logical choice will be
being that we're in baby step two we
have 53
700 plus that we are plugging away and
have planned on being done this year
um
we make between 125 and 130 on average
with our own business that can fluctuate
up and down
um
the two options we're looking at
is
number one
we purchase our own
four season
fifth wheel
stay in place because our business is
here all our equipment is here and the
day after the fire someone did try and
come in and steal one of our trucks
so there's a psychological fear there
that if we are not right here
that we could lose more by somebody
actually getting away with it luckily we
were able to get home and stop the
situation
but
it's a definite fear for the amount of
equipment we have here for our company
um do we purchase
that fifth wheel that's like seventy
five thousand dollars do we take money
out and
and do that and then use um we'll have a
stipend as well and just pay that
and i don't wanna take on more debt so
that's freaking me out yeah
or the other option is this there's
costs to bring in a conex lock
everything down build a security fence
lock that down try and get security
cameras up again because of course all
that went up in the fire as well
um
and then go to my
my amazing parents
have said we could rent the bottom of
their house from them they're not too
far away
but we have two dogs a cat they have two
dogs they're older my husband works the
night shift in the winter because we
switched from construction to snow
removal yeah cindy let's do this we're
going to put you on hold we're going to
put you on hold and we're going to hold
you over the break we're up against the
clock and so hang on the line and yeah
there's a couple of things that we want
to kind of talk through but some good
options that you presented cindy so
we'll get right back to you after this
break yeah hang on this is the ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show so we're
gonna pick up this call
from cindy
in alaska and
her and her husband were on the
journey of getting out of debt baby step
two they have 53 000 left in debt and
then they had a major house fire house
burned down
um everyone is okay
and now just trying to figure out and
navigate next steps
and what to do so
cindy would you say that covers kind of
the high level part of your story pretty
much yeah when we've gone through all
the logical decisions
we have two options now or a few weeks
into this and i want to make sure we're
making the right financial decision and
not to making a decision based on our
emotions because those emotions are
unstable when it comes to finances right
yes
so let me ask you a few questions um
first rachel and i were talking um off
air
has the insurance company circled up and
said hey here's how we're going to take
care of your housing over the next few
months
yeah we they have given us a stipend
okay so regardless where we rent
um that will cover that so i can
continue with my my regular income to
pay the mortgage and all those items and
utilities that will not affect that and
it's enough that we can get through
on that on that stipend um okay so
our loss of use and the two options you
said were to take out 75 000 to buy a
fifth wheel to be around your work and
making sure that that stays secure that
area or
create security around that and then go
move in
with your parents or in-laws um live in
their basement so my question is with
the stipend of the rent cover
if you guys just went and
got an apartment or a condo for because
you're out you'll be moving back into
your home christmas of 23 so you have a
year and a half of this journey
um so what causes what's the thought
process of not just going and renting
something else with that stipend from
the insurance company
the stipend with runs up here is not
enough okay okay so you've priced it
you've priced it out not enough for
rentals here yeah
it's it's pretty expensive and to find a
place that allows um pets as well that
increases with okay so our best
financial option would be to rent from
my parents because the rent would be
cheaper within the stipend range yep i i
do have a great relationship with them i
would challenge your insurance company
i would challenge your insurance company
because most provisions not all but most
of them are based on making you whole in
the process some have dollar amounts
attached to them like this is what this
is going to provide for you but often
they're about making you whole
okay okay in the gap and so it may be
push here's what i want you to do
anytime there's a tragedy or there's
something scary in our lives and we back
ourselves into a corner and say it's
either this or this we give ourselves
two options
rarely is that the case and rarely do we
make good choices when it's in either or
situation okay okay and so i would love
to see you all get with somebody that's
gonna spread out your because you've
boxed yourself into we take out 75 000
on a depreciating asset or we live with
my mom we would we would take it we
would pay ourselves from the business
um instead of waiting till the end of
the year and use that money to purchase
it and then after we're done with it uh
the plan would be to sell it back to the
business because we do remote jobs and
we could do better bids um by being able
to house our guys in it
um yeah i hear that there's a like i
didn't have a chance to mention yeah and
there's a part something that it feels
it starts to feel a little messy because
you're taking my personal we're trying
to do the business we're trying to
band-aid this to get this and this
and so there's a part honestly and what
john said earlier in the segment of just
resting and grieving what was lost and
just to do the simplest thing between
here and a year and a half what is the
simplest path
and so whether
and if you guys and i agree with john go
go press the insurance company to say
hey here's market rate on rent
uh you know here's what's going on and
talk to them about that but if it gets
down to i don't i don't personally think
it's a terrible idea for
to move in with your parents because
again it's a year and a half if we're
talking five years or something that's
probably a different conversation but
because of the time frame it's not a lot
there's a safety net there it's familiar
and and you guys are going to have a lot
of decisions and a lot of work ahead of
you when you're rebuilding the home i
mean there's there's going to be
you're going to be
having us having a part-time job
basically during this project because
it's going to be a lot and so i think
being able to minimize minimize as much
stress and make things as easy as easy
as possible in the next year and a half
feels feels right to me so i lean
towards um yeah moving in with your
parents again you have a time frame it's
a year and a half figuring out the
safety part of it yeah and then yeah and
then yeah circling back and figuring out
the safety part of your bed so cindy
uh and i'm gonna speak broadly to
everybody listening right now one of the
great challenges we've all faced
is this idea of
when it gets back to normal
and it can be
in my life it was when my when my wife
got pregnant for the first time and i
was like oh well whenever the baby's
born and then we get back too
and then hank was born and i realized a
month or two in like
it's probably two years till we quote
unquote get back to and i never stopped
to realize there is no going backwards
right so it's important to note in this
situation cindy you guys had
53 000
left in baby step 2 with a plan to pay
that off this year
that will not happen
your world exploded
and the more you try to duct tape and
move and shuffle and buy a fifth wheel
and the more you try to do stuff so that
you can get back to the way things were
um the more likely you are to make a
decision that you can just compound your
issues and so really the
the
the my favorite analogy is uh from the
great esther perel says you can't take
all of the dust and glass and steel from
the twin towers and sweep it all up and
rebuild those towers you have to
excavate all of it
clean it all out get architects get
engineers get different professionals to
come in and build something new arguably
stronger and arguably more beautiful but
you got to do something moving this way
and so you all need to stop and say
where are we for this year what's
reasonable for this year and then let's
make that plan happen and then we're
going to just do this on a year by year
basis yeah so good thanks cindy and
we're so sorry i'm so sorry thanks for
the call
up next is jacob and scranton hey jacob
welcome to the show hey thank you guys
so much for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
so my wife and i uh we have a question
about college savings we have a blended
family um we actually have two children
from my
relation with my late wife and i who are
14 11.
we have two children together one who is
three and one who is unfortunately in
heaven
and one on the way in september so we've
got a pretty wide age range and we're
trying to figure out how to invest uh or
how to save rather for for their college
funds and and cash flow everything
we've you know got the anthony o'neill
book um just trying to figure out
when do we
stop how much do we
save is there a number to get to or just
keep on throwing money
what do we do yeah it's a great question
so when it comes to kids savings
for college there's really two great
options an esa an educational savings
account and a 529 plan and depending on
your income and how much you guys want
to contribute that you may not qualify
for the esa so most people do a 529. um
but i would also i would sit down with a
smartvestor pro because they're gonna be
able to walk through very specific
options for you guys and run numbers
because here's the deal the 14 year old
is gonna have less than the one that's
gonna be born in september right i mean
that's just that's gonna be the facts
and so um the biggest stuff when you're
looking at college and what you're
saving for is to say okay by by the time
that this 14 year old's 18
what's realistically what are we going
to have to save um and when you look at
that number that's going to really
determine whether that 14 year old
stays in states goes to a community
college applies for scholarships and
grants but for this 14 year olds go to
school debt free is the number one
priority and so part of that's going to
come from you guys since you're on baby
step five um but there there could be a
realistic you know situation that
that you're that that you're 14 year
old's 18 and it's like oh wow we didn't
have as much money saved as we as we
were planning or what we thought and so
school choice jacob is going to be the
biggest is going to be the biggest
factor in this conversation
go ahead sorry go ahead sir i was going
to say um
there's been a lot of loss in your
family
and sometimes on the back end of that
grief is a sense of guilt i want to make
up for i want to get i want to make sure
that all this is taken care of
there is that feeling is real that
sentiment is real that desire is real
and it's good it's right and there's a
mathematical reality so it may be that
you look at the numbers and what y'all
are going to be able to do over the next
few years and you have to sit down and
tell your 14 year old i think i'll be
able to cobble together 10 grand and so
we're gonna have to start working now on
scholarships jobs grants all of it
together so that in four years you've
got enough because this is the best
we're gonna be able to do or maybe
you'll be able to save it all and it's
okay if it's different for each kid
absolutely it's gonna be the reality as
well thanks jacob for the call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsay personality rachel cruz hosting
this hour
with dr john deloney
it's a free call anywhere in the country
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five we're talking about your
relationships your money your career
your life anything and everything so
give us a call
up next is rebecca
out of portland hey rebecca welcome to
the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
i'm about to be engaged and i need
advice if i should stay with my
boyfriend
[Laughter]
you have called the right place oh jesus
it's a lot of pressure oh my gosh you're
rebecca so oh my gosh give us the story
rebecca what is happening so you're
about to be engaged you know this
rachel has never missed an episode
rachel has never missed an episode of
the bachelor
we have got you
okay go for it go for it so
we've been dating for a year and a half
my boyfriend is a recovering addict he's
four years sober
a month ago he elapsed back into youth
fast forward to last night
and i find i found out that he still has
ten thousand dollars in medical debt
that i thought he had paid off
anytime we've talked about those two
situations he's ended the conversation
by saying i knew i shouldn't have told
you about it
i love this man fiercely
but i'm really scared right now and i
need some advice yeah
so
a couple of things
let me like so
he struggles with addiction okay that
for me isn't a reason to say i'm out
right and for your sobriety and having a
rough day or
you know taking some steps back
that's something that if you choose to
engage in a marriage you know what
you're getting into and you've probably
got addictive tendencies of your own and
we're going to work through this
together the part that has given me some
significant pause that i think is this
the killer of relationships is secrets
this idea that i'm gonna have an
alternative life underneath my marriage
and i'm gonna have things that i keep in
my drawers that she doesn't know about
or he doesn't know about
and secrets there's a biology to secret
secrets kill you and they kill
relationships and so there's a deception
and dishonesty here i'm hiding stuff
from you right that's the part that man
i think your instincts
not saying you need to call this thing
off
but um i think there needs to be a um
truth-telling time like no more secrets
no more
i don't like that impulse i knew i
shouldn't have told you yeah because
rebecca though and why anybody says that
is it because you if you can like be
self-aware enough to know are you
defensive about like are you coming
after you fly off the handle get mad at
him is it like that or is it you're just
asking questions and trying to care for
him and he still has that reaction like
what what are those conversations like
i'm a pragmatist so when we have those
kinds of conversations i listen and then
i try to
like find a solution so that
conversation last night
ended because
he
he said you know um this that is old
it's not affecting my credit score
anymore
i don't have to deal with it that the
collectors aren't calling me anymore and
i said it's still debt you need to pay
it off
did you you said when you were talking
to us that you thought it was gone did
you think it was gone because the story
you told yourself or did he lie to you
that's a great question i
i'm
if i remember correctly
i'm pretty sure he told me he paid it
off or at least that's how it how it
came across that he wasn't in debt
anymore so the language you're using
right now suggests y'all might be in a
pretty common relational pattern as
people often marry or get
get into relationship with people who
struggle with addiction
because they are fixers or in your words
you're pragmatists
and i want you to be very careful about
seeing him as somebody to fix
instead of somebody to be with and often
he may come to you with i need you just
to listen to me i want you to hear me
i'm struggling i'm hurting and he's not
asking for what do i do next he's
probably a really smart guy that's had
to be pretty self-reflective to have
gone through four years of sobriety he
really needs his fiance his girlfriend
his wife his partner his best friend to
sit with him and just say this sucks can
i hold your hand
that makes sense all this is saying you
all need to have a couple of hard no
more secrets truth-telling conversations
and he may have more secrets like here's
what i need i need you to not try to fix
me
and you may have secrets like i need you
to never lie to me
never hold withhold from me
um
or this relationship's not going to work
you're going to run into a brick wall at
some point right
what's the what's the probability of him
relapsing
oh i i mean i think that would be
anybody who's going to give you that
kind of i don't know i don't know him i
don't know what the what he's struggling
with there's no way to say that right
and i think your pragmatist wants a
percentage
right you're like is it a 42 or a 17.7
but also for her sake though walking
into
a lifelong committed relationship with
someone
what what is that how do you walk down
that path knowing i'm going to choose
someone which everyone everyone's broken
right like i mean
yeah it comes out in different ways but
cocaine is different than heroin that's
different than alcohol it's different
than pornography that's different from
smoking right so
and trauma is different than people who
work 140 hours a week so it's so if
you're going into a relationship with
knowing this though for her sake
what are the questions you would be
asking
what are the things that you dig into
for her to to her philosophy because i'm
hearing from you rebecca because i'm not
a trained therapist this is why i have
john next to me is i'm like okay if i if
he's been four years that's amazing and
i'm gonna celebrate that but he's he's
gone down once is he gonna go down now
every single week for the rest of our
marriage like do you know what i mean
like you kind of go down that road
and what do you do what what is it and
that's an anxiety it's trying to grab
control i want to figure out the next
thing
exactly so here's what we're going to do
we're going to focus on a set of core
agreements that we're going to um all be
a part of and
towards a life that we want to build
right so when you sit down with a
builder and you say i want to use the
top
of the top cabinets i want the top of
the then they're going to go shop and
get them right so you all are going to
create a series of relational boundaries
and actions and agree to them this is
who we are
we are always going to tell the truth
even if you have a relapse you're going
to tell the truth
you will never hide things from me and
that means when you need something
different from the way i'm treating you
you got to tell me because that's a
secret that's a lie if you don't tell me
and i promise to right so y'all are
going to create a series of behaviors
that you will commit to
and that you will double down on and
then you will deal with life as it comes
right and
that that i think we focus so much on
the goals and the outcomes if you have
one more cigarette i'm out of here
why is that person have to smoke maybe
we've created a home that's so tense and
so toxic and so hard and not dealing
with old stuff right so let's create an
ecosystem where we can both survive and
live that's right so let's start there
but i think it starts with everybody
sitting down in a room and looking at
each other and says time to be honest
time to turn the lights on let's be
honest so good thanks for the call
rebecca this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so one of the fun new things
that i feel like we've launched in a
long time john
well we we launched it
i say we i'm adding myself into the
project you're an owner of the company
we launched them and then they kept
selling out and then selling out and
then selling out and so then the people
said well can you make new ones can you
make different ones and so here we are
here we are
okay the questions for humans yes the
card sorry it's the conversation cards
so what's fun is that it's like you have
a deck for parents and kids you got
friends and work places
and then what's this one oh yeah yeah so
all these options so anyways they picked
some out for us but they did girls night
for me well let me do them then i'll ask
the girls next question i'm asking you
i'm not going girls nights you're going
to have to do it because we're doing it
just a few girls
man this could get dicey this could get
dicey people may get offended let's get
some cancel on you ready you ready what
are three important skills every woman
should know
oh gosh
how could i
i know karate coming from a guy karate
like how to fight
that's a good one um how to uh
change a tire
okay
um
it's hard i don't know what do you think
i don't know i have no idea okay let me
just think about my like my daughter
right uh budget
you would it's ridiculous so i'm looking
at josephine i want her to be strong and
brilliant and compassionate yes right so
strength would be
can she fix stuff can she get out of a
situation that's dicey can she reach out
and make a call
i want her to be to
be compassionate and think about other
people and i want to be brilliant right
yeah it's like a there's a problem
solving wisdom aspect that i would want
yes my girls to have yeah whether you're
in whatever the situation's in
um what else is an axe throwing that
would be a good good skill
accidentally not really no
golly i don't know because you can go
super domestic
oh figures figures
figures rachel woman
uh yeah i don't know i mean i move on
okay okay
uh celebrity crush growing up
and what about now oh jennifer love
hewitt
well great throwback yeah great
throwback yeah freddie prince jr
really yeah yeah yeah
i'm not gonna lie winston's kind of a
dead ringer
kind of made that one come true like you
that's kind of like yeah
your husband has got freddie prynne's
junior vibes in a major way i can see
that okay what about now
oh
gosh my wife probably is the only thing
i can say is my celebrity crush who's
yours yeah
do you know who i just i love so much
but he's old so i don't know what that
says about me a lot hugh jackman
oh he's phenomenal i mean the man can
sing can dance attack people yeah my uh
i know how i know how darwinism works i
think hugh jackman is yeah i can see
that but he's so old so you know oh he's
not he's 48.
he is i just made that up 48 john okay
well real quick let's do one more um
mm-hmm it's fun what's fun that's fun oh
this is a great one know how to cook
would you rather have a
would you rather have a personal trainer
chef or hair stylist
chef hands down thousand percent chef
all day long all day yes what if you had
a personal chef and they just cooked
your meals
then you wouldn't need that skill as a
woman you know
i guess it's all done no a chef would be
chef would no question about it would be
incredible amazing okay so good well
anyways the cards y'all they really are
fun
and the girls night these are funny
these are funny especially when you have
a friend like i do who basically wants
to
bring women back to the 1400s that's
pretty cool
okay whatever call me call me 1950s but
i love we have a garden right now and on
sunday night i got tomatoes out of the
garden i got basil out of the car i mean
i'm like living off the land
made sauce
made this pasta with parmesan cheese and
all i mean this whole thing and i just
felt like a bad day so there is
something in me when i cook and i'm like
and i made winston i was like i'm gonna
make your plate because i want you to
like see how beautiful and she's
delicious that's not about cooking
that's about i'll show you i did this
like it's for you just feel great call
me 1950's 1950's that's very modern i
felt awesome
that's a very much of a flex
congratulations yeah you're welcome
rachel cruz living off the land you're
welcome
living off the land i am okay up next we
got
madison out of tampa hey madison welcome
to the show
hi rachel hi dr john how are y'all today
we're doing great it's doing great how
can we help
well i am in my first big girl job
outside of college and i just got my
first bonus and i wanted to know um what
y'all think i should do with it nice
congratulations madison what do you do
i'm an accounts receivable okay that's
great what kind of bonus are we talking
uh 1 100
way to go nice
so great so financially madison where
are you at do you have
do you have debt do you have any savings
kind of what your what's your financial
picture
uh i have no debt i i was able to get
scholarships to cover all of my
schooling nice um
yeah and then i have a ten thousand
dollar emergency fund and then about
four thousand dollars that i'm putting
towards a future car
good for you
and to that ten thousand that'll
probably cover you in that three to six
months of expenses that fully funded
emergency six months okay saying that if
i was frugal and keeping myself uh
accountable sure sure how old are you
i'm 23. good for you madison
you're you're doing really well for a 23
year old i just want you to know that
like you're you're killing it you're
killing it uh so for the next for the
upgrade in the car you saved four
thousand dollars for that will that be
coming soon are you doing that just kind
of as a precaution
just a precaution my family has a family
curse where every eight years our cars
go out in my cars at four years right
now so i'm just getting ahead of the
curve that's so great it's a family
curse i love it
well i mean madison at this point you're
on you know baby steps four five and six
so really
there's three things you do with money
you can give it you can save it you can
spend it so with this bonus i mean i
would give some of it i would
you could put a little bit away for for
a car you could enjoy some of it because
honestly i mean eleven hundred dollars
it's amazing it's not going to
completely you know change your whole
financial future you know um in this
moment so i would say to kind of just do
both i would give some of it
i'd put some more of it in that car fund
if you kind of want to give a little bit
more cushion then i would enjoy some of
it because you've worked hard for it or
you can spend it on four gallons of gas
that's about what it'll buy you guys
yeah definitely here in tampa exactly
for sure congratulations yeah does that
help
i think so i i'm looking forward to
figuring out um what fun thing i could
do with it yeah i want you to spend a
little bit i'll say that you've worked
hard yeah you have your head on straight
i'm not worried about you going off
going off the ranch well and this is one
of those cool things where
you do all this work so that when you
get your first bonus the question is
what do i do with this money not what do
i have to what do i get to do this money
versus what i have to do this is totally
different proposition love it love it
love it love it that's awesome um so let
me ask you a question when you think of
a millionaire what kind of job do you
picture having is it some kind of
high-powered executive like a vp or ceo
well here's the thing only 15 percent of
millionaires actually have jobs like
that and the reality is that the top
five careers for millionaires in america
are engineer accountant teacher manager
and attorney
it's just one of the surprising things
my team found out when we conducted the
largest study of millionaires ever done
our study made it clear
that
if you want to become a millionaire
you've got to invest wisely and a big
part of that is getting good investing
advice you need to work with an
investing pro who can walk with you and
teach you about the options that are
right for you i use uh smart vester pro
rachel uses the smart fest pro these
aren't things we're just trying to sell
these are things that we actually do in
our own lives and trust our with our
families resources
my team recommends trustworthy vetted
investing pros from all over the country
and we call them smart vester pros to
get in touch with a smart vester pro in
your area go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester and start building wealth
today that's ramseysolutions.com
smart vester
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show
up next is
malnet did i pronounce that right out of
seattle
did i did i butcher it my name
is
i'm sorry
i apologize they had it phonetically
next to the name so i was really trying
i was really trying i apologize
how can we help
well i'm glad to talk to both of you um
my question is
in the context of a recent divorce like
how to set myself up
financially for
best security on my own
um i'm on baby step three and i own my
house well i don't know my house i have
a mortgage but i have a house um
but yeah just kind of looking at the
long picture
i'm so sorry when when was it settled
when was it finalized in march
yeah
yeah in march
what is the what's your financial
situation
um i'm doing okay i have a day job i'm
working two jobs right now i have a day
job
and that earns 15 000 a year
and that's remote location dependent um
i am starting private practice um that's
just in the early phases but that has
the potential to grow to about
93 to 100 growth
and then i have 26 000 retirement
i owe 186 000 on my house
can you afford the payments
i can yes there are about a thousand a
month okay did you have to make a
write him a uh your husband a check your
ex-husband a check to buy out the equity
of the house
no that's one good thing about the
divorce i think because of the situation
uh let me just say this there's no good
coming out of this i can hear it on you
yeah it's hard huh
you still with us i'm really hurt yeah
yeah sorry no don't don't apologize at
all
um
the guy that
one of my great mentors um
working in mental health said this after
a major life change
after
a breakup a miscarriage a divorce a loss
don't make any major moves for six
months to a year
and what you we need right now we talked
about in another segment is you need
some time to grieve and just sit and be
sad
because you had plans right you had
pictures in your mind
and oh yeah i mean
we were gonna hold hymns at 90. exactly
and so there's a season of grieving that
loss of those pictures and then
the light slowly starts coming back on
not that it's never you're never going
to not be sad when you think about your
first marriage but
um the light comes back on and the air
is a little bit different and you keep
plugging away at your jobs because you
got to stay busy and you got to eat you
got to pay rent but
enter into a season of there's not a lot
next right now there is simply just
grieving right
yeah is that fair
oh that's very fair yeah grieving and
keeping myself functional at work yeah
that's right that's right and that's
you're gonna have to get a couple of
people around you that can walk
alongside you that you can text at 2 am
and they'll come over and they'll bring
nachos and y'all could just sit and weep
together or somebody who will get you
off the couch and take you to go
go for a walk or go for a hike or do
whatever you need to go to arcade i
don't know what you'll do but
a group of people who are going to walk
alongside you okay stay on the line
because i want to send you a copy of own
your past change of future and that's
really the crux of the book is
regardless of how well we're put
together our lives at some point
um have the bombs that go off in them
and then the question we have to ask
ourselves is
what's next like what do we do next and
that's the whole book and there's a
whole section on grief so i'll hang on
the line here and uh austin will get you
guys sent to you
yeah and it's
you know you've the the positive thing
just on a more tactical level is
with the financial situation like you're
in a really good spot yeah you know as
good as you can right yeah you have no
payments you have an emergency fund in
place you have a great paying job and
then a another one that's going to even
make you more in a house that's really a
low payment on it yep so so in that just
just hear me say that the resting that
that is a possibility just to like like
there's some people it's like okay we
gotta
kind of keep this we gotta keep the ship
afloat even though there's grief in all
this but you have like secured
everything so you're good you're good if
you did nothing financially for the next
six months you're gonna be okay
so just breathe more in that loss of
that marriage and what you thought was
and like john said get a good community
around you
um but financially you really are you're
doing um you're doing a fantastic job
and i would just keep kind of plugging
away but there's no rush on anything
anything
does it exist pile up cashier
like just to put cash into a savings
account or mutual fund and just could i
would still be okay with funding put
investing during that yeah i mean i
think there's still some if there was
something you guys were working towards
but since there's that she has a house
she you know all the big stuff i feel
like is pretty much covered yeah but i
would not make any major decisions
though i would not up and sell the house
yeah don't do that or quit your job or
spit you know take all your money and
just blow it and spend it because
because of the grief you know like you
really do you want to
you want to stay the course and what
you've been doing but there's no need
just to like sprint ahead on anything
crazy so when i am so sorry but thank
you thank you so much for the call
up next is phil and lancaster
pennsylvania hey phil welcome to the
show
hey guys so grateful to be with you
thank you absolutely thanks for calling
how can we help
so uh my wife and i are
are trying to make a wise decision and
and we're kind of stuck um we're trying
to figure out whether or not we should
do uh 3b next or if we should jump into
four five and six
um we recently paid off all our debt
thank god uh we're projecting to have a
fully funded emergency account by the
end of december nice congratulations
thank you so much um uh yeah a lot of
hard work but so so glad we found your
program um very very helpful uh thank
you so we're
gonna have another eight month season
where i'm going to be away from the home
uh my wife's gonna be playing single mom
so we're we're approaching that season a
lot of emotions and so we're just not
sure where to go from here um the home
we currently live in uh we're planning
on using the equity from selling that
house to buy a new house
uh and the reason we're moving is
because i accepted a job uh in a new
location and so uh that equity will go
into the purchase of a new house but we
weren't sure if once the fully funded
emergency fund is in place
if we should start uh piling up money
for a down payment on the house via 3b
or if we should just be doing four five
and six to increase the equity in the
current home uh for when we're prepared
to make that move
yeah it's a great question i would i
would save up 3b i would save up a good
down payment
um during that time do you guys have do
you have you run any numbers phil on
when you guys move when you plan on
moving roughly how much equity you'll
have to put towards the new house
yes so
and our primary residents will have uh
190 thousand dollars equity once we
close uh the sale
um and then we also have a shore house
uh which we purchased before we found
the program uh but thankfully that was
part of the debt we paid off and so
there's 140 000 equity in that house
but if we don't have to sell it that's a
great vacation home for our family we
prefer not to yeah for sure so the 190
you'll have in equity how what kind of
what what do you think the new price the
price of the new house will be when you
guys
move do you have a ballpark
we put a ceiling on it at 400 000 just
because we're not comfortable taking out
a mortgage of more than 200 000. yeah
okay then that's great then i mean i
think kind of with actually with those
numbers you have a ton of equity to go
in so i so i'm gonna kind of
rewind my my answer phil now after
hearing all those numbers then i would
start plugging away at four five and six
um and be paying down the principle of
your house you'll have more equity and
then when yeah when the time comes to
sell you'll be able to roll right into
the new house
awesome thank you so much appreciate the
clarity yep absolutely grateful for you
man thanks for thanks for calling
a lot of house discussions recently
still moving it's a mess out there man
the market the market is still
still a little all over the place but um
but man you guys it all goes back to
math look at math and numbers that's
going to be your friend during all these
decisions this is the ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five find
out for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promo
codes that run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
today's question comes from sabrina in
new jersey sabrina writes
i listen to dave and agree with most of
his views oh this is going to be awesome
i love these
[Laughter]
me too sabrina me too
i listen to dave and agree with most of
his views but not
on sharing bank accounts with your
spouse
i like steve harvey's advice to share a
bank account for the bills and then have
one for yourself and one for the other
spouse
i see couples fighting all the time
about what the other spends money on my
sister and her husband argue about
the way she buys her coffee i'm engaged
to be married and my fiance and i don't
want the same things when it comes to
finances how can we avoid that i think
your sister's married to a jerk
he gets mad about how she buys her
coffee what does that even mean unless
they are broke and she's ordering nine
dollar
double latte expressions
i literally had in my head that they're
at the coffee shop and she's ordering
he's like why would you do that what
would you put probably just like how
expensive it is
i like went to like the order not
specifically the price so that's fair so
here's the thing to answer this question
i'm engaged to be married to my fiance
and i don't
want the same things we don't want the
same things when it comes to finances
how can we avoid that don't get married
really right or does they not with the
same things like her sister has
no
she is engaged to be married and
her fiance and i don't want the same
things when it comes to finance right um
either don't get married or have some
hard conversations and get on the same
page because yeah i'll let you rachel
what do you think
you're always telling people to share
bank accounts yeah always because in my
head
yeah you see couples fighting all the
time about the way the other spends
their money and to me
that's not just a money issue it's not a
money issue at all like we go back to i
mean it's a it's a marriage thing are
you guys on the same team are you
working towards the same goals yeah to
your point are y'all trying to get out
of debt and once spending money over
here
when they shouldn't be well that's less
about again the dollars and cents in my
head and that's more about respecting
each other and the plan that you're on
and working as a team to get like that's
a whole other conversation it's coming
out
that way
and then my other thing too is when
people avoid because i hear this a lot
well
people fight a lot about money so it's
just not worth it it's easier to have
separate accounts
because if we had the same accounts then
we would fight about money and like well
then the fights that
you would have are the fights you you
should be having those are the
conversations you gotta have then you
gotta have those conversations you can't
just avoid hard topics in marriage by
putting a band-aid and having separate
accounts like it just doesn't it doesn't
work and to steve harvey i've heard i've
seen the clips of him and i'm like in my
head
having the same account where you each
still have your own spending money of
course there's a rachel line item in our
budget there's a winston line item even
our kids they each have their own line
item because it just makes things easier
like here where are we at with you guys
in spending in the month and so
i still have the freedom i'm like i
still have my id i'm still rachel and i
still i'm gonna enjoy spending things on
on things that winston could care less
about winston spends money on stuff that
i don't really care about but but i'm
like hey we both agree this is the
amount of money so to me regardless of
whether it's in a separate checking
account
or not to me that or the same you still
have the idea that you still have money
to spend individually right and the idea
that if you put it together then you
lose any of the things that you would
ever want any of your autonomy it's
nonsense yeah it means you have to have
a shared conversation about shared goals
yeah right roommates have separate
accounts
couples who are together for the long
haul and walk through
so if you're married
have one account and if conflict comes
up because of it good then you're going
to work through it
so let's let's let's let's pull us apart
for a second sabrina
when you ask when you say that you and
your fiance don't want the same things
when it comes to finances
as a guy who works with couples this is
a big red flag not because of the money
but because somebody wants to have a lot
of cars to work on in the driveway
somebody wants a home somebody wants um
to retire someday somebody wants fill in
a blank these are questions about how
we're going to live our lives what we're
going to do together and more
importantly what we value
and
that what it finances is just the math
part of the what do we value question
and so you all have to get in a room and
say do we want to value peace and do we
want to value laughing deeply and going
on vacations and enjoying our lives or
do we want to value
a suburban we can't afford and um
sending our kids to college is that
they've got to mortgage their souls for
whatever the question whatever values
y'all come up with that's the question
and that's
your finances a line after the values
question yep absolutely
up next is andrew
in knoxville tennessee hey andrew
welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
i'm new at this and i'm just trying to
figure out how to get out of that and
everything so uh it's great you called
the right spot
okay so
so that so you're just trying to figure
out what's your situation
uh
i'm 70 000 in debt
okay
what kind of debt is it
that's my home
just your mortgage okay yeah that's my
mortgage do you have any consumer debt
car loans credit cards student loans no
i no i have no other debts that's great
andrew how much money do you make a year
what's your what's your take-home pay
um
my wife's
household will be uh 72 000. okay
a year that's awesome
uh do you guys have kids
yes
how old are they
uh five and six can be three okay that's
great
and do you guys have any money saved
uh yes i got seven thousand dollars
saved okay
that's great andrew
well what we teach here um
on the show is really this step-by-step
plan
on how to get in control of your money
get out of debts
have an emergency fund all of that and
andrew you're you're far down the line
which is awesome because you're doing
great yeah the first step is a thousand
dollar emergency fund so check the
second is pay off all consumer debt but
your mortgage check
the third is to get a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
so you're getting there with that seven
thousand dollar
uh emergency fund how much
and again you don't have to answer right
now but i want you and your wife tonight
to sit down
and figure out okay with all of our
expenses how much do we need and for you
guys you know you have little kids so i
would lean closer to the six month just
for some security purposes of having
that that just extra
extra cushion and so figuring out okay
how much more do we want to add to that
seven thousand dollars you may be close
to it depending on your your expenses um
but what do we have to live off of
for six months to be okay if we had no
income coming in and that's really your
that's what your fully funded emergency
fund and so you're gonna put that aside
just in a traditional savings account or
a money market account
and do not invest that money this is not
an investment this money really is
insurance that if something happens
a pandemic hits someone loses their jobs
your air conditioner goes out uh med you
know a medical emergency and you need
cash like all of that id it's your rainy
day fund
and then from there andrew you're gonna
start after that's complete you're gonna
do baby steps four five and six together
so you're gonna start funding retirement
do you guys have anything in retirement
right now
yes yeah we made her both have
retirement okay that's awesome so you
want to be funding 15
of your income into retirement and then
the next step is looking at kids college
so for these this five five-year-old
three-year-old look and say okay well we
need to start putting some money away
for them to have money for school
and then that last that that baby step
six is paying off the home early
so doing all those three steps together
is really what you're looking at so um i
would i would do a couple things andrew
are you guys budgeting do you guys have
a written budget
oh no
written budget but just
you know just do like every typical
people do just you know not go out to
eat here and do that yep absolutely okay
so i want you to hold on the line andrew
austin's gonna pick up and we're gonna
give you a year's subscription to ramsey
plus which is gonna include our every
dollar budgeting app
and financial peace university which is
gonna be the full nine course
uh lessons that you need to really get
all of this in place i know i can't
answer it quickly on a phone call uh
this short but i want you guys to go
through that you and your wife together
and follow exactly what we say and you
guys are gonna be doing great you're
doing great already andrew thanks for
the call
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i am rachel cruz hosting
at this hour
with dr john deloney answering your
questions about career
relationships money
life
all the things so you can give us a call
a free call anywhere in the country at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five
up first this hour is jessie out of
grand rapids hey jesse welcome to the
show
hi hey thanks for taking my call you
guys i appreciate it so much um i feel
like i'm calling a couple friends oh
thanks well i've read your books and i
listen every day and we are um my
husband and i are both big fans we're
only about two years away from baby step
seven ourselves so amazing
yeah congratulations yeah
thank you but i'm trying to not let the
pta wreck my life
so
i say this because um i got involved a
couple of years ago and
you know involved with the treasury part
and the president part and and
a lot of it's not familiar to me
but the stress of
the finances is so hard because
our you know our personal finances are
are keyed in and we got that figured out
i'm just trying to come up with a way
for this pta group to really be
successful financially
we have almost 35 000
i just feel like from the outside
trying to help organize
how the bookkeeping is done how the
transparency is done there's just not a
lot of financial options
out there
to do this and so what i was thinking is
is every dollar a good
option and if i could propose this to
the group you know what your thoughts
are because i know obviously rachel
every dollar is
is your thing and so i'm wondering what
you think yeah
well i think i mean so you're saying use
every dollar for
the pta for your kids yeah school yeah
for the school to keep track of all the
expenses that come out of it
the funding that comes in how often does
is it funded for you guys like how often
do you guys need
what happens is you know every two years
you hand this off to a different group
and so everybody historically has done
finance is different there's a
spreadsheet that was given to me that is
just mind numbing to look at
so
you know we have money coming in from
different events every month much like
income from a book fair or uh ice cream
sale or something we've got income
and then we have events that we do so we
budget and plan for that
so it's really the same exchange it's
just there's a lot more hands involved
and you know i know the previous caller
was talking about a marriage i feel like
this is even harder because there's
about
10 of us oh it's so much harder
like it's like i just i'm trying not to
let it you know this is the stuff that
when i can only imagine people are
stressed about home finances the way
they feel yeah
we don't we fortunately don't have that
i mean it takes me 10 minutes to do our
budget but the pta is like keeps me up
at
night you're such a good member of your
community jesse
so jesse sometimes um
i'm just laughing i've worked with
multiple ptas and they they do great
great work inside of schools and they're
always an adventure is probably the
nicest way i can say that
yep a lot of times
yeah so rachel i i don't see a problem
with using the budget i'm sorry yeah to
answer your question i think it's
totally fine and i think you know you're
instead of a home category with
electricity and rent more
it could be a event like whatever the
event is and you have listed out
specifically
the expenses out of that event and you
guys keep track and the thing with every
dollar though is that there's one every
month so it will roll over to the next
month which
shouldn't be a a huge issue you just
would have to keep track of
yeah money coming in money going out all
of it but yeah i think you totally i
think you totally use every dollar and
just link that bank account
um or the school account to the app
and then again it's it's a all the
categories are completely different than
what a household budget looks like um
but having the line items and stuff i
think it'd be a great way to track it i
think it's much easier than except than
like an excel sheet where i've seen ptas
be really successful is when
they do the hard conversations that
aren't about money but they're about
values what do we want to do this year
and what do we want to accomplish and
then let's let's duke it out and
vote and get mad and whatever until we
come up with a list of priorities and
then the order of the priorities
and then those can create budget
categories for you and then
following through it becomes pretty easy
you don't have to lay at night stressing
over where the money's going to go
because it's going to go to the next
value property it's going to go to the
next priority and the next priority
after that and if we have anything left
then we're going to buy you know
computers or we're going to buy whatever
the thing is or throw the big party at
the end of the year but it just becomes
about
let's let's have a values conversation
in a priorities conversation and then
money will flow from there
love it all right up next is tashay from
buffalo welcome to the show
hi thank you absolutely how can we help
so i'm currently upside down on my car
loan
it was originally a 72
term loan
i have 25 payments left to make on the
car
my monthly payments are 359 dollars each
month
uh the kelly blue book value for the car
is forty nine hundred dollars and right
now i owe ten thousand five hundred
dollars on the car
okay so yes i'm very upside down did you
roll another car into this purchase
no i didn't
how did it get so
how did it get so upside down i haven't
heard that at all the last 24 months
so the original loan amount was for 14
000 and my interest rate is 20.2 percent
when i got the loan i honestly was a
little bit younger and i really needed a
car quick because my last vehicle was
totaled i had gap coverage my insurance
paid the whole thing out so i kind of
just didn't look at the terms i looked
at the monthly payment and saw i could
afford it and that was it yikes
so we learned we learned our lesson
right
oh yes
never never again
i'm 26. okay hey
i learned this lesson at like 38. you
won okay so you'll never do it again
it's a ten or five to ten thousand
dollar
uh
let's celebrate that for what it is is
that cool
cool yeah all right it is what it is and
we're going to move forward on it
but uh i am right stick to my stomach
for you yep okay so
so
what what's your income what do you make
a year
um right now i make 32 but i just
accepted a new position that starts um
in august for 39. okay um and i'm doing
gig work outside of that as much as i
can how much do you think you'll make
doing that
um
probably 45 000 between the job and okay
uh gig work yeah that's great okay
and what other debt do you have besides
this car loan
um i do have student loans i have 22 000
of student loans
and then i also have 8 000 of credit
card debt i'm using the snowball method
to pay off okay
that you're using what to pay off what
did you just say
the snowball
okay yes i've already
yeah i've paid a couple cars off already
so i just have the one did you have a
big one that's 8 000. okay do you have
any savings
um i have 500 in savings okay but the
car keeps being repaired every month so
it's kind of eating away at the savings
yep absolutely
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna keep you on the
line because i want to circle back and
just give you some points on how to how
to attack this
and what to do next so stay on the line
we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
so right before we went to break
[Music]
we had to share on from buffalo and
she's upside down on her car
uh
she can kelly blue book it right now for
4 900 0's at 10 000
has credit card debt student loan debt
and
is yeah just trying to try to figure out
really what to do next would you say
that's a the overall picture
yes yes that's accurate
okay so
for where you're at in the car so you're
saying it and it needs repairs
consistently
yeah so in the last three months i have
spent 350 dollars at least every single
month for the past three months
and i just want to sell the car at this
point and trying to figure out if that's
the best thing to do
or what's wrong with it
um
they say it's normal wear and tear so
just new wheels new tires
getting brakes fixed and things like
that it's just all kind of happening one
after another i suppose
usually
here's what i don't want you to do i
don't want you to get annoyed with a car
that's got regular maintenance stuff on
it and just get so frustrated you just
sell it and then put yourself in a hole
um
i understand if it's if you're telling
me the transmission's going out and then
the alternator's broken and we have some
real problem like
then there's some systemic issues with
the car if you've had a of just a really
bum run of luck the last three or four
months you got to change this and change
this get the brakes
then man then i'd say
just bite down on your mouthpiece get in
there and swing a few more months and
hang on to this thing is that you know
what i mean
yes
yeah so looking at your numbers and
everything i mean
one option is yeah you you sell the car
you take out a five thousand dollar loan
for the difference and then
you are where you are with no car
so that's not a great option because
you're going to need a car so you could
pause the debt snowball save up a ton of
cash go get a 1500 car crappy car that's
going to get you here or there but it's
reliable
and you're going to drive it for for
eight months save up some more cash on
the side a little bit sell it replace
you know keep moving up slowly in car
um that could be the option
or
uh knock out this credit card debt
work like insane hours like i'm talking
like 60 hours a week you have two extra
jobs you just go nuts on this
and pay off the credit card the 8 000
and
the car the 10 000 car loan that you
have currently um and then look to see
okay can i sell can i sell it after that
so those are really the the two the two
options and both kind of get you where
you're at now if you
hate the car
and you're just like oh would you rather
yeah take out the difference in a loan
put that and be paying that off because
that's gonna be smaller than even your
credit card
eight thousand dollar bill
and
go drive a crappier car but could have
maintenance too right so i mean yeah
we're never going to tell you you should
go
take out a car alone
okay and
get out of this mess like i i like as
rachel as you were saying that
it sounds like
the next three or four years of trading
and hanging on and doing some repairs
and then
upgrading a car to get right back to
this same 4900 car right
i'd rather see you pause the baby steps
and just
repair this thing get it knocked out so
that's going to keep you going for the
next 24 months or something 18 months
right um paul i'd rather you just stop
and get this thing taken care of and
then just say this is going to be my car
for a while i am upside down i signed uh
i made a bad deal and we're just gonna
hammer this because really the math that
we always say is if you can't pay the
car off in 18 to 24 months then you need
to sell it
but the 10 000 to where you're at
i think you're i think you're gonna be
able to pay it off i think you could if
you went
which went bananas yeah and that's the
other thing is is in this season of the
debt snowball and all of it i know it
feels like setback you know when you
have these repairs and all of that
um but man if you if you can just
you know make another 20 grand
25 grand a year doing extra stuff part
time you know three or four nights
that you're out you know driving uber
eats whether it's that or it's walking
dogs like i don't care what it is but
it's amazing what people are paying now
for jobs oh yeah and labor than what
they were even 12 months ago i mean like
what you can make
doing things and even getting creative i
mean i've heard people now are renting
out their backyard so it's like an app
to run out your backyard for like a
party or something and so people are
doing that for a night and making like
400 bucks and it's like
sure why not i mean i don't know the
last uber ride i took the
guy just on the way to work flips on his
light and he says i just make an extra
50 to 100 bucks on the way to work and
then all the way home and i just pick up
somebody in my neighborhood who's going
to the airport or something yeah and he
leaves 20 30 minutes early and so
there's
it's a matter of figuring out and it's
also the other side of the equation you
cannot eat out for the next 12 months
you cannot buy another item of clothes
like you got to shut down spending um
and get this stuff this is scary broke
stuff this is scary stuff you're not
safe let's get this stuff paid off yep
so the expensive side of your life is
going to be really important cutting
everything back and then upping that
income but yeah but when it comes to the
car i know it's frustrating but what you
were hearing even it's kind of normal
repairs well you have a car here's what
i would do like if that's my sister
that's me that's me i would take that
car to a mechanic that i trust and say
what's it going to cost out the door to
get this thing up to where it needs to
go
like wheels tires brakes what give me a
price all across the board what's it
gonna cost and then i'm gonna pause the
baby steps for a few months save that
money up and go get it all done so then
i can drive this thing on and i'm gonna
let that rage and that anger like i hate
this car i hate this car i hate this car
that's gonna propel you to work those
crazy hours and those wild jobs and get
this thing paid off and move on
all right up next is cindy out of omaha
hey cindy welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
so um my counseling i started reading um
total money makeover to get on the same
page for finances before we get married
and i'm getting ready to sell my house
um because i'm gonna move to florida
where he is
and i'm just trying to figure out um
will be debt-free
after i sell my house and pay off my
student and my car loan i'm trying to
figure out what to do with that extra
part if i should fully fund my roth ira
because i am self-employed
um so i don't have a lot into that or if
i should just save all of that for
looking at a house we are going to wrap
for probably the first year so we know
exactly where we want to be
yeah that's great so how much money will
you have left over after you've sold the
house paid everything off how much how
much cash will you have
about 30 and so i should actually say we
are going to take and put 16 to fully
fund a six-month emergency fund okay
okay that's great so you'll have 14 left
yeah um yeah i mean i would go
and and again you guys are you're going
to rent for a little bit so there's not
really a house discussion you you could
put it away and just know hey here's a
great down payment
uh heading for a house you know in not
nine to 12 months when we start looking
um but i do love the idea too of funding
funding your roth putting some cash in
there
and continuing on that so um
i mean either one's fine the 14 grand i
mean it's a it's a great amount of money
so even if you took a little bit funded
the roth kept the other in a baby step
3b
saving up for a down payment uh just to
get you guys a head start i think is
awesome
so that's probably what i would do i
would take some out and fund the roth
and then i would leave the rest in an
account specifically for a down payment
and then continue to save towards that
uh making sure that yeah it's a if you
guys can hit a 20 down payment in a year
that's that's the dream
okay
awesome thanks so much yep thank you
congratulations on your new marriage yes
good luck
so fun and premarital counseling reading
uh total money makeover good for them
it's great that's fantastic get on the
same page
absolutely
okay so what do you do when you come
across something that helps you in your
life and it helps your life go better
well you tell your friends about it and
so
whether it's a great book you've read a
new restaurant a movie you just tell
your friends about something awesome
that you've experienced and so that's
one reason why the ramsay show has grown
to be one of the biggest business and
finance shows really in the world
because millions of you tune in every
single day and help share
it with your friends and family and tell
them about how it has completely changed
your life and how you have used the
stuff that we've talked about on the
show to change your life and they share
you know how they've cut up credit cards
how you guys have gotten out of debt and
build wealth and how your marriage
and relationships are so much stronger
and you've reached your career goals so
much around this so whether you found
this on podcasts youtube local radio
don't keep it to yourself share your
favorite episode of the ramsay show with
your family with your friends and help
them
get hope that they need in our world
today because no one should miss out on
a good thing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show up next
is
i'm going to do this y'all i'm going to
do this guadalupe
i was about to do it oh guadalupe
let's see if i got it right from des
moines did i get it right
yep guadalupe guadalupe beautiful so
great
what's up
um well i just want to see how i can get
better at saving money
um we're currently on baby step number
two okay
but um
like i think i know how to but it's just
getting there
like i need somebody to like help me out
um
we uh
i don't know where to start we we make
over 120
120 000 a year
and
we have a brand new truck
and we have some medical bills and then
we have the house and then
that's all we have
for debt but i i'm like
i just feel we should be able to put
more money away
yep
okay so how much is the truck payment a
month
the truck payment is 400. how much is it
in total what's the total loan as well
26 right now currently we owe 26 on it
okay 26. um and
uh um
but it's it's uh
um it's we have a lot of uh how can i
put it to fitus
yeah we buy a lot of things
so it's just trying to like figure like
and and we don't know we don't need
those things that's just so why do you
buy them
um
it's not me
um it's my husband
he likes to he likes hobbies he likes to
you know just go and get it now
and i'm more of the i'll put something
in my cart and i'll be there for months
until i finally commit that i actually
need it
um so it's just trying to convince him
like how how can i it's more how can i
convince him how to stay
and how we don't need all these things
um
is he on board with
when you bring up paying off debt
all of that what is his he
he doesn't like having debt like to it's
it's more like how can i it's
i've been listening to your guys's uh
youtube channel and
and it's like
you think you're normal because you have
a a car payment
and to me i'm just like we have a paid
car already we don't need to have
another car payment if we can pay this
car off
asap
it'd be awesome but like
we we also have cred like we have credit
cards and we're i'm paying three
thousand dollars a month on credit cards
like they get paid off every month but
yep i'm like we can be putting that
money towards savings yep and it's
trying to
like
i've i've used the word dave ramsey
you know like dave ramsey says he's
right here let me i want to try a new
track okay um often we get stuck in a
rut and we try the same tactics and they
don't work
and then we get frustrated so we tried
the same tactics just louder and angrier
and yep harder and then they especially
don't work okay
so you and or your husband
get something
from getting a new package in the mail
or from having a shiny new there's
something that is bringing your body
something right you're getting some sort
of benefit from this even though that
benefit might be killing you like just
think of cigarette calms you down did it
right now in the moment and it kills you
right
so i want to try a different track
instead of talking about dave ramsey
instead of talking about let's pay off
our debts let's pay off for debts
instead of talking about math problems i
want you to sit down with your husband
and say i'm scared
okay i am terrified
that we are going to spend ourselves
into oblivion
i'm tired of waking up at 2 am unable to
breathe
i'm tired of you having to take extra
shifts i miss you you have to take extra
shifts so that we could pay this 3 000
credit card bill off of just crap stuff
we don't need
and i'm not i don't feel safe in my own
house anymore would you be willing to
join me
in creating a home that we both can go
in
let's start there
because now
now getting out of debt is part of a
path that y'all are gonna take together
towards a common goal it's not about
math you'll have math problems and
you'll have great discussions and i want
a new bow and arrow yeah well i i need
tires you'll have those discussions and
disagreements and fights and they'll be
spectacular
but they will be in service of a greater
identity and that is we are a family who
is safe and we're a family that doesn't
borrow money because we are never going
to be slaves to somebody else that's who
we are and now let's create the
behaviors that fill that up you see the
total difference there
yeah
one is nagging about oh my gosh you got
a new truck uh and one is
um when you pulled up in that new truck
i didn't think you look like a big tough
cool guy
i thought oh no how are we gonna make
this payment and then i couldn't breathe
yeah
right that's a totally different
conversation and if he's uh a husband
who looks at you and goes ah get over
yourself now you get a harder
conversation yeah then you got some more
marriage marriage stuff yeah to dig into
but
but in the obviously the perfect world
is that he says okay okay and honestly
for i have found with the spouse that's
reluctant but wants to get they're not
like totally against the idea but
they're like i don't know logistically i
don't even know how to get if you can
map out detailed
detailed
the debt
how much could go each month towards the
debt what you would cut out create a
budget and just say hey if we cut out
this expense and show them and show the
math though and show the pathway out
because your husband
probably like john and i are is the
spender of the relationship john and i
are both
each of our marriages
and so if i if if my husband came to me
and was like hey sell your car
we're never going out to you can't go
shopping get off amazon
we are paying off debt i'd be like that
is not a fun life so i don't know what
life you're living over here but like i
want to enjoy life but if you told me
hey i as your husband
i don't i i am stressed i am freaking
out i can't breathe everything right
that john just told you to say if my
spouse gave came to me and said that and
said and here
here is what the next 26 months could
look like of our lives and it's not
going to be fun because it does mean i'm
not going shopping i may have to sell my
car whatever sacrifices are involved but
there is an end game
if he can see the end game that hey you
can get back to enjoying stuff because
we're not against stuff i think people
think that about the ramsey solutions
like oh you guys are so cheap i'm like
no
we are for stuff we just don't want your
stuff to have you and you guys are in a
position where it has you whether it's
spending because it feels good and
you're stressed
or and you're spending with money you
don't have so now you're going into debt
for it so
so we we can have stuff later in life
that's not the problem but how we're
going about it is what is killing us
and so having that that timeline i think
really helps see and um an end game
versus this being a forever long path
and you guys make great money yeah
you're doing good you make great in des
moines iowa it's not like you're making
120 in manhattan like you know what i
mean like you guys are you're in a
position where you can do a lot and it
may mean sacrifice of lifestyle and and
i also want you guys on a budget i mean
because if you're not being so specific
with your paycheck yes it's gonna
four or five hundred six hundred dollars
can slip out you don't even notice
because you're just spending and so
really you guys getting together and
saying hey we're gonna do this together
and locking arms and knowing like this
is a new way of life for a certain
amount of time of the sacrifice so we
get out of this debt
does that help
yes yes it's i i call it my
my little notebook and i showed him like
he finally looked at it
and he's like and his eyes just got big
and i'm like this is what i'm explaining
like we need to like follow
everything in and i also don't want you
to be his mom you're not his mom in this
process either i don't want to feel like
his mom yeah he does like he likes like
he likes nice things and he works really
hard but i'm like
we shouldn't just be paying off the nice
things because you were you do work
really hard
it's both and we work really hard and
then over time we can afford nice things
if we take something out on payments i'm
just borrowing it from the bank it's not
even mine it's not even mine
like i want stuff if i buy something i
want to be mine right yeah you don't
want to own you want to oh yeah you want
to own it you don't want to owe on it
thanks for the call this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
do not remember the past events pay no
attention to things of the old look i am
about doing something new
even now
it is coming
do you not see it indeed i will make a
way in the wilderness rivers in the
desert isaiah 43 18 through 19.
identity is a person or identity is a
prison you can never escape but the way
to redeem your past is not to run from
it
but try to understand it and use it as a
foundation to grow
from the great philosopher
sean carter a.k.a
jay-z dude you gotta brush that dirt off
your shoulder hey uh can you
guys in the booth can you pull the
scripture of the day back up
did i mess it up well you didn't call it
out so
all of a sudden you just
say like today's scripture the day is
you all sudden you just said
do not remember the past events
the old rivers and i was like what
what's happening here
and then i realized what the time was
fantastic
you start speaking this old
oh well it was fantastic one of my
favorite moments ever in the show's
history
that was the scripture and the quote of
the dead
thy river is in the desert i will make i
will make new ways well guys she's
officially uh
checked out it's the last segment of the
show we got this all right
all right john from dallas
welcome to the show you're up next
hey guys how are you doing today
we're doing great how can we help
um
so i'm 21 and my wife is 20 and 25 weeks
pregnant
um oh congratulations
thank you
uh we are on baby step two with our only
debt being ten thousand dollars in
credit card i say only debt but it is a
lot
um
we have no personal car i have a company
car and they also pay for my gas and
insurance
um a co-worker has a hybrid that i could
buy
um its value between seven and eight
thousand and he would owner finance it
to me
um
but my wife is currently working as a
mother's helper for her aunt
she pulls in about 1200 a month i make
about 2500 a month with my uh overtime
so 2 000 salary about 500 extra a month
in overtime john what do you do for a
living
i'm a uh administrative assistant for
uh my uncle okay
um
you said about 2 500 a month
she's pulling in 12
1200 so 3 700.
so you're about 30 about 30 a year with
overtime
uh right around there yes sir okay
what's your what's the long-term play
being an executive assistant to your
uncle
absolutely so there's um
he's one of just the smartest people i
know um
uh by the time he was 21 he made a
million dollars the wrong way as you
guys would say it um got into a bad
motorcycle accident lost it all and
now has just crawled his way up he's in
his uh early 30s now and and is
just super successful
um he's able to find
ways to make money and everything and
there's a lot of um
what is your long-term
uh occupational situation that this is
this is getting you that way
and this is this is heading in that
direction
absolutely so entrepreneur i want to
invest in some of the things he's doing
um there's a rental car business that i
manage
that i'll be able to put my own cars
into
um
eventually at no cost
uh no management cost um so he's
teaching me how to get better at sales
flipping things flipping cars
[Music]
and then there's also
an energy business that i can do sales
in as well so how much
how old are you entrepreneurial skills
21 21 okay
um
if you are
working on say so let me let me put this
way if you are using if you if you say
i've got 24 months where i'm going to
make 30 000 a year
working overtime with a with a toddler
busting my butt
and but i'm using this both as um a way
to scratch out a living because you're
going to be scratching it out but this
is basically graduate school for you you
are learning invaluable skills and
you're getting put put in positions that
you wouldn't otherwise be for a
long-term game
um and here is the end date to this
fine
if you are doing sales and you are
managing an entire fleet of cars you are
being
dramatically taken advantage of
big time you're worth more than 30
dollars if you're doing all that work
and so either
you've got a short i i don't want to see
you your family suffer because you've
got this dream that keeps getting punted
and punted and punted and punted down
the road while you're making thirty
thousand bucks
okay
um you work too hard and you're you've
got your dreams your aspirations are too
big
right
um
so either
say hey uncle this is awesome i've got
to put more food on the table right now
um absolutely one thousand percent do
not borrow money from your
don't refinance it don't do that do not
do that um but i do think you need a
second car
and so you need a car that you own
because does your uncle technically own
the car that you drive
yes yes yeah you need yeah you guys need
a more individual family
situation
you're in a very precarious situation
because one day he gets mad and
everything in your life goes away
so think about it as fishing
you have one line in the water and a
child and a spouse and you sitting right
next to you saying i hope this one bob
or you're not gonna do that you're gonna
have lines everywhere
and you've got one job that you're being
dramatically underpaid for
his car
is is managing your whole life
right and you just like i say you work
too hard man you work too hard you're
too smart you get too big of dreams to
sit like this so either sit down with
him and say this is a month plan and i
want to know what the next move will be
um or hey i love you uncle you're great
and you're wonderful but i gotta go make
fifty thousand dollars because i got a
young family to take care of now
see what i'm saying do you feel the
pressure with the baby coming john how
how has that changed the dynamic for you
absolutely i mean it's been there for
the last 24 weeks
yeah yeah of uh
you know how do i increase this
um
income and yeah there's you know off
there's
there's unlimited opportunities um and
i have
really learned so much and gain so much
experience sure
but you've got you've got a math problem
right now
and maybe this this unlimited
opportunity it shows back up in 36
months because for the next three years
i got to go make sixty five thousand
dollars yep um running on a yard crew
and because here's the two here's the
deal cheaper or whatever yeah you make
different decisions
when you're out of debt you have money
in the bank and you have margin
you make different decisions you breathe
yeah you can breathe and so this um
it doesn't feel peaceful to me it feels
like oh gosh i'm running running which
you would be um you know with your
situation and where you guys are at not
having really a car and baby coming all
of that and so there's something john
you're 21
and i'm like you have
the amount of careers and jobs that
change from 21 to 45 people's lives i
mean it's all over the map and so i'm
not saying that that what your plan is
and in your head is never going to come
to fruition but there's a part of me if
i'm your wife too
i'm like the dream goes on pause like we
got to put food on the table we need to
get this debt paid off we need money
coming in for diapers and for like like
our life is about to just kind of turn
upside down with this baby coming and so
there there's a time and a place i think
that says hey you're young enough
honestly your age is encouraging to me
you know i'm like if you're 45 and
you're having to change career jobs
it's a harder turn because you've been
in it for longer and so you know because
of your age and everything i'm like man
i i would be tempted john if he can't
show you a increase in salary or the
value that you bring and a change in pay
coming up pretty pretty darn soon
um i'm gonna probably just say hey i
gotta pause this i gotta go make some
money and and take care of my family
again for a short period of time don't
have to be forever john but i would love
to see you guys clean this mess up
even if your wife can work extra from
home well even while she's while she's
expecting do something to to clean it up
so don't put your family further in debt
no don't yeah don't go get the car alone
do it save up pay cash for a car
absolutely
all right john thanks so much for for
hosting today thanks to
ben
zach andrew austin for a great show
happy friday america we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsaysolutions.com
[Music]
you